معنا من اسطنبول حسين اوروج نائب رئيس
هيئه الاغاثه الانسانيه التركيه سيد حسين
نحن في اليوم السابع ماذا عن اعمالكم ماذا
عن الصعوبات وماذا عن الامال في وجود
ناجين
كما اسلفتم مره ما يقارب اسبوع 180 ساعه
بعدما حصل لقد انقذنا الكثير من الاشخاص
من تحتها الانقاض في المناطق المنكوبه
وهذا اعطى الامل لكثيرين وهذا الامل مستمر
ان الكثيرين منا حسيبوا ان هذا سوف لن
يحصل بعد ثلاث واربعه ايام سوف يكون صعبا
ان ننقد الارواح ولكننا انقذنا الارواح
اذا هذا امر يسجل في التاريخ انه واقع صعب
وهنا نود ان نشكر كافه فرق البحث والانقاذ
1500 من هذه الفرق لا تزال موجوده على
الارض تعمل على مدار الساعه اضافه الى ذلك
لدينا الكثير من الفرق الدوليه للبحث
والانقاذ التي اتت الى تركيا قرابه 10 شخص
يعملون جاهدين لانقاذ الارواح نحن نعمل
على الارض ونحاول ان نحل مشاكل الناس
البرد قارس لاسيما في فتره المساء والليل
باسرع ما يمكن يجب ان نوفر المساكن
والملاجئ للناس فهذا اكثر الحاجات الحاحا
على الارض لا سيما لضحايا الزلزال نحن لا
ندخر وسعا من اجل ان نسهل قدر الامكان
توفير اكبر عدد ممكن من الخيام ان قدراتنا
محدوده في تركيا اذا الحاويات بالاضافه
الى الخيم ضروريه الان نناشد الاسره
الدوليه ان توفر لنا حاويات بمثابه مساكن
وخياما للمنطقه هذه الاولويه
هل لديكم ارقام او تقديرات عن عدد الذين
يحتاجون الى الخيام عندما نتكلم عن مقاومه
البرد وايجاد ماوى مؤقت له
الى المتضررين فهم يقاربون 13 مليون شخص
متاثر بزلزل ومنهم من لم تتضرر منازلهم
تماما هي ربما متضرره جزئيا ولكن هناك على
الاقل مليون شخص بحاجه الى ان يتم
ارسالهم
في حاويات
ومساكن مؤقته بالنسبه الى ما تبقى ربما
نجد لهم اماكن اخرى كذلك ما الذي نفعله
نحاول ان نخرج
المتضررين او الذين نتضررت منازلهم الى
مناطق اخرى حيث جهزنا لهم مساكن
معاوي او ملاجئ انسحها القول وسوف يتم
استضافتهم في تلك المناطق في المدن الاخرى
وعلينا ان ننقلهم اليها اما الحاجه الاخرى
فهي المساعده الغذائيه اليوميه هي مهمه
الناس عاجزون عن تحضير طعامهم في المطابخ
الجماعيه او المجتمعيه نحن نحضر الطعام
ونوزعه على الضحايا هذا ايضا مهم
بالنسبه الى رسم الرعايه والنظافه هي ايضا
مهمه بعد انقاذ الناس
وربما بعد يوم او يومين سوف نرى ان عمليات
البحث والانقاصه تتوقف وحين ذاك
ستبرز الحاجه الملحه لهذه الرزم هي مهمه
جدا ويوما تلو الاخر نرى انا حاجات الناس
تتغير
وبالتالي فان تبرعت النقديه ايضا مهمه
من الماط التركيه كلها ناشطه وفيها ما
يكفي من مواد الغذائيه ومواد النظافه
الشخصيه
وبالتالي نناشد الدعم وارسال المساعدات
دعونا لا ننسى ان هذا زلزال حصاله في
تركيا
وبالنسبه الينا نرى ان
التاثير اكبر بكثير
مما توقعنا لاسيما في سوريا
الناس وفرق الانقاذ وفرق الاغاثه بالنسبه
الى سوريا قليله جدا نحاول ان
نساعد سوريا قد راى الامكان ونقف بجانب
الشعب السوري
بالنسبه الى عدد الوفيات وعدد المصابين في
سوريا فهو ضخم جدا كذلك لا ننسى ان البنى
تحتيه للرعايه الصحيه في سوريا
مقيده او محصوره جدا وهي حتى صارت اكثر
هشاشه بعد الزلزال اكثر من 100 شاحنه
نقلناها
لتنقل رزم الاغاثه من تركيا الى سوريا
اكيد ان الكثير من الناس يشاهدونك الان
وهم يرغبون في التبرع والمشاركه في مساعده
اخوانهم سواء في تركيا او في سوريا ماذا
تطلبون من هؤلاء الناس كمساعدات في هذه
المرحله
يجب ان نتحرك ونعمل سويا وليس بسعيد فردي
وهناك تنسيق جيد بين الحكومه التركيه
والمنظمات غير الحكوميه نحن جزء من هذا
التنسيق في انقره حيث مركز التنسيق وفي
المدن حيث هناك ايضا تنسيق في مجال
الاغاثه والانقاذ نحن بحاجه الى دعوه
الحكوميه التركيه والدوليه للمشاركه في
جهود التنسيق هذه ونحن هنا في تركيا
مستعدون لتسهيل الموضوع ان الكثير من
المنظمات والجمعيات من الدول العربيه
والمسلمه تواصلت معنا وبدانا عمليه
التنسيق
ما اقوله لاطلاق هذا يعتبرعات الرجاء
الرجاء تبرعوا التبرعات النقديه ايضا
مفيده يمكننا وبسهوله تنسيق حاجات الناس
وتلبيتهم اذا هناك افراد او شركات او
هيئات في العالم الاسلامي او غيره اذا كان
بامكانها ان ترسل باسرع ما يمكن هذا
الحاويات التي تستخدم كملاجئ ومساكن يمكن
اذا ننسق توزيعها اضافهنا الخيام نحن
بانتظار دعم الاسره الدوليه دول مختلفه
لاسيما من دول الخليج العربي الجميع
بانتظار هذه الحاويات التي تشكل مساكن
في اسطنبول حسين اوروج نائب رئيس هيئه
الاغاثه الانسانيه التركيه شكرا جزيلا لك